how's it going with my name and welcome
to our class it's probably one of the
most anticipated horror games of 2013
libros have been literally upset about
me for not playing the demo which was
out on at PAX so they were nice enough
to get and let me play it and yeah I'm
excited I'm excited as hell all right
[ __ ] it before I talk too much let's
begin that's good okay welcome to pax
but I'm not in packs you're about to
become miles huh okay after getting an
anonymous tip you travel to Mount
massive asking them to find out what -
the miracle corporation giving chase
pages when you survive the main door is
locked and nobody seems to be around but
that doesn't stop you there's a story
here and you will get to the bottom of
it just remember you're no fighter to
survive the horrors of the a saloon
you'll have to either run or hide I like
that
not sure about the story but I guess
we'll uncover a damn [ __ ] it finally
a pretty horror game this feels like ah
ah you know I hate so many shitty horror
games and I don't know this just make me
appreciate a beautiful one you know that
is amazing all right well I guess whoa
look at that this is pretty diamond Mart
I have a sweet-ass jacket holy [ __ ] all
the single ladies I guess we have to be
creative to get in this acelin oh here
we go a perfect little liner
sorry that it's not 100% dark I can't
record after a certain hour and it's I
know whatever to jump over guys press
spacebar I'm gonna do wall jumps and
[ __ ] who did that
oh oh that's pretty cool
it reminds me without scaring to fear
when you go down the ladder or whatever
no I don't know why I wonder if I can
jump died from dumping we're not gonna
try that [ __ ]
Oh an open window - [ __ ] oh oh I'm fine
I'm fine Russ we just need to use your
camcorder hmm it's like I'm on YouTube
this is pretty freaky though
damn this looks [ __ ] awesome fire
fireplace
I know why you say something tell me but
you never know
press and hold you still allow
I kind of like the cap what are you
doing hey guys you're not what was that
the [ __ ] are you doing baby um well I
better now watch it think how why are
you all sleeping with your eyes open
that's kind of creepy
I used to sleep this too so it's okay
what is this a battery I guess I'll take
it okay
it's pretty damn awesome so far I like
it thank you thank you what if we got
creepy corridors squeezed through by
moving far right all right it's good I
like it I like it so tight that's okay
what do we got another battery okay I'll
take it
it's very dark and hard to see this room
looks awesome let's go in here any
parties up in here
why was there blood then okay well this
is not so bad
never mind I'll go in here
coca-cola drink yet [ __ ] y'all do shut
up I'm busy Tammy
jeiza skies are making not a nice I need
my coke okay
let's invest again on this guy what are
you doing this looks really awkward oh
wow rule one in horror oh that's nice
horror games there's always [ __ ] in the
toilets I don't know why they put that
as rule no can I flush god damn it this
game is not as awesome as I thought just
kidding it's they have Cola drink it say
it's all good all right now what do we
have here it sounded like a what down
haha someone what is that
alright I'll take that all right I guess
we need the batteries for the camcorder
or whatever oh oh hell no why is there
blood on the roof oh that's gonna I know
why why am I the only one yeah spiderweb
why am I the only one going through this
hello
oh oh there's how the people ever find a
big deal okay
we can't go they I guess we'll go yeah
well is that I have a camcorder you go
with a cat yo you going on YouTube okay
don't [ __ ] with me don't [ __ ] with me no
you don't holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you let's
lift up buddy hey that that what look
what you then moisture says introduces
you don't speak that ass watery what my
suspect
oh you have a face what is it but look
what though these heads are so cool
I guess you lost your virginity huh
I'm happy for you Rodriguez I'm a
Trellium can I have your arm or arm I
guess it doesn't work that that is some
[ __ ] creepy I am running out of
battery or die
well [ __ ] [ __ ] happens yellow okay we're
going to here hey hey hey no no we don't
we don't want to we don't want to talk
with don't no not today brother I don't
want to talk to them why you have to run
out of battery you piece of [ __ ] Bob
wait I have more than ha
let's finish but hey I may have Viking
blood but it ain't working right now
okay I'm just gonna [ __ ] crawl my way
through this [ __ ] honey honey Hey okay
shut up
battery you can you don't know me you do
whoa look at this I'm crawling it's
awesome okay we're fine it's all get in
the head I know peg I'm at Lisa giraffe
Jack's are way cooler uh-oh
oh yeah and who are you
I heard the [ __ ] are you
[Music]
I see merciful God possible why is your
voice echoing sighs what you have a
colleague how did you get your face of
both wait that doesn't make it sense
okay
I am [ __ ] loving this game so far
this is like the game I've been waiting
for it's interesting it has good scarce
and I can be on youtubes oh my god
find a way back to the main floor okay
no problem
hello okay I reload the battery Jesus
Christ camcorder who uses cam cutaway
time using one right now okay we're fine
squeeze through
I don't need my camcorder oh cool it may
be a little dark peek oh [ __ ] Allah okay
we're good
this looks so real with the [ __ ]
camcorder I hate it don't be too rich
realistic surprise that phone didn't go
up play out less they said it will be
fun
well I'm not having okay well why do you
always throw me why did I ever do to
yell stop place I'll film you I'm family
okay you look okay you look hot you look
hot you look hot Oh Oh Heidi Heidi we're
good we're good we're good
he can't fall hello Rodriguez oh nice
what I thought it was gonna throw in the
bed I wouldn't like that please for
[ __ ] sake I'm just a man I'll be your
woman if you want you okay fine why do
you have to throw me no no no take me
home country roads place
[Applause]
[Music]
country roads take me home
I was not ready for that [ __ ] peach yeah
that'll help a bunch of [ __ ] okay
all right let's reload our useless gun I
got your tape
I gotta sue you I got ya goddamn I don't
think I'm not gonna do it okay just
don't touch me
we're fine okay we're going here now
that's blood that's fine don't worry
about it
wow that said yeah oh how nice
boy hell better boy boy boy have it away
with ever and ever
hello how's it i'm watch i don't have
any balls if that's what you ask
they just went inside my body
who said that
yeah nose
I can hide in here whoa Oh steady so
awesome I think I think I think we're
good too
Oh what [ __ ] are you doing I like to rub
my nipples too but geez do it in private
okay he bugged out that's a shame but
hey it's an early rest of the game
that's an order okay open up and up and
up and rod rod rod rod rod what are you
doing what are you doing hi
chan mode
we're fine No ah ah ah why me why me Shh
okay I'm a fraud I'm a fraud hello
bye he left he left [ __ ] we're awesome
Russ Oh Jess cry so bow you otter you
gotta be in every goddamn game ever
especially horror once what is that oh
you have a battery oh yeah win this
round barrel
what is this can we get up here so oh
hello I'll go here
that's pretty awesome yeah doing good
breath doing good why is my [ __ ]
thing always running out of battery
Jace's Christ he's [ __ ] Chinese piece
of [ __ ] okay don't don't make these
noises is that the exit Oh what are you
doing here Pitts what I I'm just I'm
just gonna go to an accent you can never
leave it yep
you don't know me yes I do pants I know
you're shaking your butt hi hi a lot of
boys shave their butt okay I just don't
like wait a headache
I'll shave yours too God did he just
[ __ ] tore my torso off
oh wow okay that was one hell of a
[ __ ] ride holy [ __ ]
that was [ __ ] amazing I love that
that was just ah finally the horror game
that I've been waiting for you know
Kadett it's kind of like taking I don't
want to make comparison actually but I
still think it's pretty damn amazing it
had it some bugs but as you saw with the
monster or whatever but [ __ ] it I mean
it's an early build of the game then
obviously it's not gonna be represent
perfectly what their final product is
gonna be anyway I hope you bros enjoyed
watching please leave a like if you did
I'll I'll play this as soon as it comes
out also be sure to check out the latest
episode I did with Jesse Cox on Polaris
I'll leave a link in the description for
that and all of that
stay off the bus
[Music]
Oh